SHANEE NISHRY: Cardboard
is a virtual reality viewer
anyone can make.
But how does it work?
My name is Shanee,
and in this video
I'll show you how
Cardboard works
from hardware to software.
Cardboard creates a
window into another world,
with a little help
of your phone,
allowing you to travel the world
from the comfort of your seat,
and gamers like me to fly a
spaceship and fight dragons.
It does that in
three ways, leaving
you to concentrate on making
the best possible experience.
It provides visual immersion,
takes to user's movement
into the virtual world, and it
allows for user interaction.
Let's take a closer look
at each of these features.
To make the users
feel as if they
have been taken
to another world,
we need to have them
visually immersed.
The screen of a phone is
small and if [INAUDIBLE]
close to a TV
monitor doesn't make
you feel like you're inside.
We need to focus the user's
field a view into the screen.
The box and lenses, together
with the picture on the phone,
create the 3-D effect
needed for virtual reality.
When looking through
the viewer, the lenses
focus the wide field of
view into the screen,
making it appear closer
and bigger than it is.
This means all the
user can see is
the screen and
the virtual world,
putting them inside the game.
To make visual
immersion convincing,
the user needs to
perceive depth,
just like we do in real life,
or else things will look flat.
To give the user
depth perception,
the screen is joined in a
split-screen configuration.
That is, there is a separate
and slightly different
image for each eye.
To illustrate that,
think about your eyes.
Each eye sees the world from
a different perspective.
In the virtual world, a camera
is deployed for each eye.
Each camera is slightly
offset to correlate
with the position of the eye.
This creates the stereoscopic
effect and an illusion of depth
making the brain think that
the virtual space is real.
All this together solves
the first challenge
of achieving visual immersion,
except there is still
one problem.
Even though we can't
see it from here,
when looking
through the headset,
the image looks as if it were
stretched along the edges.
This happens because the lenses
cause distortion to the image.
This effect is called
pincushion distortion.
To fix the image,
an opposite effect
called barrel distortion is
applied and post-process,
creating a seemingly perfect
and undistorted image.
Now that we solved
visual immersion,
let's take a look at correlating
with the user's movement.
The user needs to move in
the virtual world just about
the same way as they
would in the real world.
To do that, virtual
movement must be correlated
with physical movement.
Luckily, we have all
the tools we need.
Phones have motion
sensors, including
accelerometers and gyroscopes
to track orientation.
Using these sensors, Cardboard
can track your head movement.
So when you look around,
the virtual camera's
follow your head.
Back to your to do list.
We have just one challenge left.
We talked about drawing
an image to the screen
and looking around, but how
do we interact with the world?
Looking around is
nice, but not enough.
You could connect a game
controller to your phone,
but we've made it much
more simple and accessible.
This is where the magnet at
the side comes into play.
Moving the magnet
creates a distortion
in the magnetic field.
The magnetometer
sensors in the phone
detect it as input,
which can then
be used to trigger an action.
And that's how
Cardboard puts the user
inside the virtual world.
Now it is your job to create
the next virtual reality
experience.
Check out the Cardboard website
for the SDK and code samples,
and follow up on the next
videos where I will explain how
to program for Cardboard.
Until next time.